انجاز يشبه المعجزه اعاده الامل بالمشي
بطريقه طبيعيه لذوي التشوهات بالعمود
الفقري الطبيب المصري هاني عبد الجواد
ارتبط اسمه باجراء جراحات اعوجاج العمود
الفقري الخطيره والتي رفضها اطباء اخرون
ايناس طفله سودانيه اصبحت اليوم ايناس
جديده هي قالت ذلك في سعاده وهي تقف سليمه
بجوار والدها والدكتور هاني انتشرت صورها
بشكل كبير على مواقع التواصل قبل وبعد
العمليه الخطيره التي غيرت من شكلها تماما
من ايناس الى الفتاه الاماراتيه هند
والشاب احمد والطفله هناء كلها جراحات
اعادت لاصحابها طعم الحياه الدكتور هاني
عبد الجواد او ساحر العمود الفقري معنى
اليوم في صباح العربيه نتعرف معه على اصعب
الحالات وكيف يتخذ قرار اجرائها
على كل من القاهره ينورنا استاذ مساعد في
جراحه العظام بجامعه الازهر الدكتور هاني
عبد الجواد ووالد الطفله ايناس بكري علي
محمد اهلا بكم نورتونا عربيه شكرا على
تواجدكما معنا ابدا معك دكتور هاني يعطيك
العافيه ونبارك لك هذا الانجاز الطبي
العظيم يعني نجحتم في علاج اناس من تحدب
نادر في الظهر في عمليه خطيره ودقيقه جدا
حدثنا اولا عن هذه العمليه
صباح الخير يا فندم واشكركم جزيلا على
الاستضافه الكريمه
الحياه ايناس زي ما حضراتكم شفتم كان
عندها نوع من التحدب النادر جدا
وده خلاها موطيه لاكثر من مستوى الركوعي
يعني
النادر عند ايناس ان التحدب بتاع العمود
الفقري ده شيء ما هواش نادر ده شيء شائع
موجود عند كتير من الشباب ولكن مهما كانت
درجه التحدب كبير ومهما كانت الحاله خطيره
ده ما بيخليش الشاب يوطي زي ايناس كده فهي
ايناس كانت حاله فريده من نوعها
وده كان اللغز اللي عند ايناس ان احنا
يعني دايما حالات التحدب ديت بيبقى عمليات
حسابيه يعني هنعمل كذا فنحصل على نتيجه
كذا فهو صعب عند ايناس كان ان احنا ناخد
قرار لانها حاله فريده جدا ان هنعمل ايه
فناخد النتيجه ايه يعني لحد انا ما طلعت
من العمليه وانا واثق ان انا عملت حاجه
كويسه مش متاكد انها تقدر تستقيم فهو ده
كان
الغريب في اناث يعني دكتور هاني فقط يعني
لكي نستفسر عن المشكله من الاساس هل هذه
مشكله تبدا مع الولاده اما تاتي في كحاله
نادره مثلا تطرا على جسد الانسان
اشكرك على السؤال لان ده هو التحدب دهوت
ده ليه انواع عديده جدا في تحدد بيكون
نتيجه
فقره مشوهه
منذ الولاده فالفقره المشوهه منذ الولاده
ده بيبدا يمنع نفسه التحدب بعد الولاده
على طول وفي تحدد بيبدا يجي مع النمو يعني
بيقرا يبقى الطفل عادي جدا وييجي مع النمو
يبدا يحصل له تحدد والتحدد دهوت بيزيد وفي
تحدد بيكون ثانوي لبعض الامراض فالتحدب له
انواع عديده يعني طيب دكتور ايناس استطاعت
الوقوف بعد ست ساعات من اجراء العمليه
تحديدا هل يمكن القول انه ايناس عادت الى
حالتها الطبيعيه وهناك انتصاب كامل للعمود
الفقري والظهر
اه الحقيقه يعني هو دي كانت المفاجاه
الكبيره ان هو يعني انا فعلا زي ما قلت
لحضرتك ان انا بعد ما طلعت من العمليه انا
مش قادر استنى عايز اروح اوقفها يعني
ايناس كانت الصبح بتمشي موطيه بطريقه
رهيبه جدا وبس عشان نفهم موضوع موطيه ده
يعني لو حد ما عندوش حاجه يعني هو ما
عندوش حاجه خالص ولكن حاول يمشي بطريقه
التغطيه دهيت لمده دقيقه واحده لا يحتملها
البنت كان بقالها اكتر من سنه ونص بتمشي
بالطريقه ديت فكان ان هي تستقيم سنه ونص
مش عارف حتى تنام على ظهرها فكان ان هي
تستقيم وان هي تطلع من العمليات نايمه على
ضهرها ده كان لوحده
انجاز او فرحه كبيره بالنسبه لنا كلنا
واكيد يعني بنتمنى السلامه لايناس لكن هل
هذا يعني بان اناس اليوم ستعود الى المشي
متنها مثل اي انسان وبذات الطريقه ام رح
يكون في مثلا زمنيه محدده علاج معين
هي بالفعل بتتمشى من يوم العمليه زي ما
حضرتك اشرت من بعد ست ساعات بالعمليه ولكن
ايناس لسه العمليه بتاعتهاش عليها اسبوعين
فهي ما زالت لسه في فتره النقائها وفتره
التعافي لكن الحمد لله هي منتصبه القامه
وبتمشي واموره كويسه
يسعد صباحك اهلا وسهلا بك معنا في صباح
العربيه استاذ علي استاذ علي اولا بنقول
لك الحمد على السلامه ما بعرف اذا استاذ
علي معنا سمعنا حمد لله على السلامه يا
استاذ
الف سلامه لايناس الله يسلمكم اكيد مثل
هيك اخبار يعني بتفرحنا واكيد انتم الاساس
اللي بتفرحكم يعني تشوف بنتك فلدت كبدك
اليوم
سويه وسليمه ايضا في ظهرها بس بالاساس انا
حابه اعرف يعني هذا المرض النادر والخطير
كما وصف كيف جاء لايناس بالاساس
أول صباح الخير على صباح العربيه صباح
الورد
ونحن بنحييك الاخت سهام ولغت نادين
والدكتور القامه
ومفخره السعاده يعني بالنسبه لكل المرضى
والناس في بلدي وفي كل البلدان
اهلا بك بالنسبه لايناس
الحمد لله بالنسبه لايناس يعني فرحه لا
تتصور ايناس يعني فتره بتاعت سنه ونص لا
تنام مثل
اخواتها ايناس فتره سنه ونص حتى الاكل ما
بتاكل كويس ايناس في كل حياتها يعني كانت
توقف بسبب المرض ولكن بفضل الدكتور والحمد
لله الان ايناس بصحه جيده وان شاء الله
ربنا يقبل الصحه الى ابعد مما نكون ان شاء
الله نعم طيب
استاذ علي اليوم كمان بس بدنا نعرف انت
كنت عايش مع ايناس كل الوقت كيف كان وضعها
مثلا كيف كانت تمشي تدبر امور حياتها
اليوميه بهذا الوضع الصعب وهذا التحدب
ايناس هي هي قويه الحمد لله
ويعني كانت حياه صعبه جدا ايناس كانت في
الشارع يعني عندما نذهب الى ونحن في
الاطباء يعني كانت تنادى بانها معوقه
ايناس يعني عندما ياتين الزميلات في
الدراسه للزياره كانت تبكي بعد الزياره
لان ترى ان هي خلاص قد توقفت عن
الدراسه
ايناس في كل حياته كانت صعبه جدا يعني خلي
بالك ان هي سنه ونص لا تنام على ظهرها سنه
ونص لا تاكل خوفا من الانحناء الخطير
فهي في فرحه جميله جدا وكونها هي من اخطر
العمليات في العمود الفقري
والحمد لله الحمد لله من قبل والحمد لله
من بعد اكيد ونحن نتمنى لها الف الف سلامه
ومنشكر كمان الدكتور هاني عبد الجواد على
كل جهوده شكرا جزيلا لكم دكتور هاني عبد
الجواد والد طفله يناسبك يعني محمد